I'm Kyle Burkholder and I'm a scout master with Troop 333 out of Peoria, Illinois.
This edition of the Scout Master podcast is brought to you by backers like me.
Thanks a lot, Clark.
And now for you, Scout Master.
This was another not so great week as far as jokes go and scouts,
because I tried to tell them the one about the sidewalk
but it was already all over town.
Yeah, oh my. hey, this is podcast number 337..
Well, welcome back to the Scout Master podcast.
This is Clark Green.
Let's take a look and see who's been in touch.
We'll go to the mail bag.
I heard from Morgan McDermott, who's an assistant scout master with Troop 20
in Winnetauk, Illinois,
And he said I was listening to the podcast about the scout
who was disillusioned by recent events and he did not want to
recite the Pledge of Allegiance.
You'll remember that
That was a couple of podcasts back, I think.
But Morgan goes on to say: my own son is a new second-class scout
And over the last few months he's been struggling with the dichotomy
between the ideals and philosophy he's been learning in the Boy Scouts
and the many realities out in our very large and diverse nation
that he's been following in the news.
What I tell my son, is that our country is an unusual and complicated
creation, that our founders came together to create an ideal
of what society could be: free, equal, just, fair,
with room to live in peace for those who live, speak or pray
differently than we do.
I tell my son, the flag we wear on our uniform and scouting itself
represents an ideal of what America could be:
A nation that is mentally awake and morally straight,
A nation that helps other people at all times,
Wherever a person finds themselves on the political spectrum.
their ideal America will share much with what a scout
pledges in the oath and law.
In my brief and wonderful time in scouting, I've learned that
there are as many reasons for being in scouting as there
are people involved.
No two scouts. no two scouts seem to come at the program
from exactly the same angle or seek exactly the same benefits.
I think, though, that if we were to examine the words of the oath
we take and the law that we repeat and the pledge that we give,
all three represent a goal, a height that a person and a
people as imperfect as we- and we all can be- strive to become.
Wow, isn't that a great thought?
I'm going to repeat that.
I think that if enough of us were to examine the words of the
oath we take, the law we repeat and the pledge we give, all three
represent a goal, a height that a person and a people as
imperfect as we and we all can be, strive to become.
I couldn't have said it better, Morgan,
I really appreciate those thoughts and I appreciate your
perspective on the issue.
We're about aspirations.
We're about opportunity and encouragement rather than
compliance.
When we encounter some pushback from scouts about these
things, it is a precious opportunity to look into them,
not only for them but for ourselves.
Thanks again, Morgan,
Really appreciate that.
Oh, there was lots of comments on last week's podcast
because I was talking about trying to come up with a
one sentence job description for every scouter everywhere
at all times.
Now, folks kind of got that, but they also offered some
things that, while weren't in the same vein as what I
intending, are definitely worth sharing.
One that I really like came from Daryl J Van Dyne, who's
been a scout master for 42 years.
He says more power to you, Daryl, and Daryl wrote
this in reply to last week's podcast. in scouting,
No one sits on the bench, and lots of folks like
that one.
I do too.
I think that's a great picture, isn't it?
Nobody sits on the bench.
Everybody's an active player in scouting, and Jeremy
added, with a good sense of humor.
Jeremy added, with the possible exception of the adults.
and yeah right,
The adults can sit on the bench all they want,
but no scouts.
If I remember correctly, I put it this way at one
time in the deep, dark, dim past:
No scouts on the sidelines,
No scouters on the field.
How about that?
Oh, we could have a lot of fun by just sitting around
and doing sayings all day, couldn't we?
Chris Ackley wrote about that podcast.
My philosophy was number one- I'm here for the boys-
And number two when it comes to all the politics
and other things that get in the way. you go back
to number one.
I like that one too, Chris.
That's a good thought.
Carl Melvin Bennett, who is an Eagle Scout and a
60-year veteran of the Scouts, chimed in to remind
us of what has been said all along in scouting-
I think I quoted Baden Powell-
It's building character, citizenship and fitness
in our youth.
Shane Cunningham, again with a really good sense of humor,
that most of you have said, taking ordinary boys
and turning them into fine young men,
And all of these are all parts of the puzzle, right?
If you remember, my one one sentence job description
was building character by applying the patrol method,
And there were a lot of comments about preparing
boys for something, and I get that.
I think that's important. but I just want to point
out we're in the opportunity business.
I'm going to repeat myself for the 70th time
that we're in the opportunity business and aiming
at opportunity is really the key.
Aiming at developing a particular set of skills
or types of behavior. it's different.
It could be a subtle difference, but I think
it's an important difference, especially when we're
assessing our efforts.
We are aimed at building character through applying
the patrol method.
I also heard from Jeremy Steinmeier, who is
an assistant scout master with Scout Troop 303
in Orinda, California, and he run in to say
thanks so much for the podcast.
I've been working my way through back episodes
and I'm feel like I'm on the fast track
to adult leader education.
I completed my introduction to outdoor leadership
skills training all three months ago.
Last weekend I went to an all day lead training,
but I'm not sure if I know about lead and Jeremy
wrote it as like an acronym, LEAD- put on by our council.
but I can't believe how well I was able to keep up
with more seasoned scouters on scout issues.
You make it clear that you do not represent
the official voice of scouting, but perhaps you should be.
Oh well, that's a very kind thing to have said, Jeremy.
I appreciate that.
I'm really glad that there is not an official
personality or an official voice in scouting.
It's all written down. you know, with over a century
we've pretty, you know, you've got to figure,
we've got it kind of figured out at this point,
except for, you know, some of the, some of the logistics
changed, but the point, the aim, the big stuff,
that hasn't changed.
So yes, Jeremy, very kind thing to say. but boy,
I'm glad I'm not the official voice of anything much.
Frank Maynard, our pal Frank
Now Frank has a blog that's aimed at those
that serve on troop committees.
It's called Bob White's Blather.
It goes beyond just troop committee stuff. but boy,
I'll tell you, I keep my eye on that blog and you should too,
And I'll have a link to Frank's blog in the podcast notes.
but I had a little trouble with the pronunciation
of an Ohio town last week and Frank wrote in to say:
you've probably heard, but Cup Master Scott is probably
in Alleria, Ohio.
Aha,
Okay,
So I was not working on that,
I was. I did not get that one right that I, Frank.
Indeed it was Illyria and it's E-L-Y-R-I-A which it makes
sense now that I know how to pronounce it, but boy,
it was giving me a problem last week.
I'm hereby make amends to all of our listeners in Ohio
and elsewhere who value the correct pronunciation
of town names.
Frank also wrote that he's enjoying the podcast since
the break over the holidays and commented that telling
folks show me where it's written when they tell you
something about scouting is a good response to most
of the nonsensical assertions that we sometimes hear.
Well, thanks for that, Frank, and thanks for being
in touch. every week
I try and have at least one live chat session.
Sometimes we're able to fit two in, but usually
the live chat sessions will happen on Tuesday
or Wednesday mornings.
Keep an eye on our Facebook feed and our Twitter feed.
You can come along and join us, as did Rob,
who's an assistant scout master with Troop 235
in North Plainfield, New Jersey, and Eric Patel,
who's an assistant scout master for Troop 81
in Chelmsford, Massachusetts.
The scout master of Troop 301 in Ontario,
California, checked in Scott Jones,
who's with Troop 911 in San Antonio, Texas, was there,
as was Ted the scout master, Troop 45
and Glen Ellen, Illinois.
All of these folks showed up on the chat session
for their first time this past week, along
with a long August list of frequent flyers
who check in on a regular basis.
Once again, it's at scoutmastercgcom.
Keep an eye on our Facebook feed and our Twitter feed.
Jump in, join us during the chat.
We have a great time doing it
And, if you do, I'll mention you on next week's podcast.
I want to pause for a moment to thank all the folks
who are scoutmastercgcom backers, especially this
week. I want to mention James Chaplin, Lisa Murray,
Eric Mondrush, Kyle Burkholder and David Metz,
who've added their names to the list of scoutmastercgcom
backers since our last podcast.
I want to say thanks to so all of you who support
the blog and podcast through Patreon, including
Daniel Luktefold, who became a Patreon subscriber
since our last podcast.
If you want to become a backer or join our Patreon
subscribers, visit scoutmastercgcom.
You'll find links to follow at the top right of any
page and links in this episode's podcast notes.
Well, the remainder of this rather brief podcast will
be taken up with the answering of an email question.
So let's get started.
Shall we
Send it by name
Email? that is, folks.
And here's an answer to one of your emails.
I heard from Brad Watts, who is in St
John's, Florida, where he is part of the committee
of Troop 287.
And Brad wrote in: I'm the treasurer for our troop
and our committee has been talking recently about
our next round of fundraising.
It has been a very adult, heavy undertaking. because
of this and some other things,
I've been thinking about something you wrote
or said a while back.
I don't remember if it was during a chat or in
a blog post or maybe on a podcast, but it was
about money and scouts, basically kind of shielding
the scouts from the money.
If I understood correctly, when I first started
as the troops treasurer, I was really latching
onto the idea of letting the scouts take on a
bigger role with the money,
Thinking that working through the scribe was one
small way that, as treasurer, I could support the
idea of our troop being youth led.
But whatever it was that you said or wrote got
me to rethinking this idea that all this money
stuff isn't really what scouts is all about, that
it's better for the adults just to handle the
money and fundraising so the scouts can get on
with doing what scouts do.
When I think of it that way, the character
building we're doing here really does come
more from camping in the outdoors and using the
patrol method. the money is just kind of almost
static distraction and a bother really.
And I'm beginning to think maybe you were right.
I continue to try and work with a scribe a bit
anyway, mostly because we have a scribe and
he needs something to do. but honestly I don't
see a whole lot of benefit in it for him and
I don't get the sense that he's at all
interested in it. and honestly, who could blame
him As an example? several times I've tried
to coach him to take some questions back to
the Patrol Leaders Council about do's.
When I follow up it's never been addressed,
neither no time or no interest, and probably
at least a little bit of both.
The troop has had a practice of collecting
one dollar a week in do's and this goes
into patrol envelopes and the former
treasurer was taking care of all that
themselves. and I've handed the responsibility
over to the scribe rather than keeping it
myself, hoping that the scribe would respond
and be interested in it. but it doesn't
really seem to be working out and I'm
honestly not convinced the idea is worth
saving. I figure that our scouts will
learn math and money, maybe for a
merit badge or maybe in school, somewhere
better suited for that lesson in scouts.
they're having fun in the outdoors,
learning character and leadership, and
they do get some practice working
within budgets for things like grub
for campouts. I'm hoping you might
elaborate on your thoughts in this
area and help me pull together my
somewhat fragmented thinking. Well,
Brad, I really appreciate your frankness,
and it's not often that I get to hear
from treasurers, especially ones
that are making an attempt to do what
you do, and that is try and devolve
as much of the responsibility and
activity involved down to the youth
level. give them the opportunity to
take on some responsibility and learn
a few things, and I think the whole
subject of scouts and money is a sword
that kind of cuts both ways. Now,
for many years we attempted to collect
cash dues and I think it was similar.
I think it was one or two dollars a
month and, man, it was like pulling teeth.
we had the little envelopes, we had
the troops scribe, we had patrol
scribes, we had it all lined up in a
way that theoretically it should have
worked perfectly. but through many, many
years- I'm talking a couple of decades-
I had one, at most two guys who
were in the position of scribe, who
really brought a whole lot of energy
to this and made it work. the other
guys kind of did it begrudgingly
because you know that was what was
expected of them and they didn't do a
very good job of it. and, long story
short, the committee decided several
years ago- which is probably more than
a decade, maybe more than 15 years
now- that we would discontinue the
practice. the scouts never missed it-
I don't think they ever missed any
big opportunities to learn any big
things. it just wasn't working and
we decided the scouts could do other
things that were more beneficial,
commensurate to the effort involved
in it. and it helps us clarify kind of
the dividing line between scout and
adult responsibilities. now anybody is
listening to the podcast long enough
knows that I think scouts should take
on the responsibility for everything
they possibly can take on. if they can
take on collecting money and doing
administrative tasks and paperwork and
things like that, more power to them.
let them after it, let the adults work
with them to make sure that that
things are being accomplished properly.
but that's only one side of the sword.
the other side of the sword is we
have a finite amount of time that
young people are able to devote to
scouting at this point, and so whether
or not that's really an optimal
opportunity for them is something that
you've got to judge. where you are with
the scouts that you're working with.
I'm not saying one way or the other
is the ideal thing. what I'm trying to
do is just explain from my experience
where we were and where we ended up
and, like I said, we decided adults
would end up being responsible for money
and paperwork and the scouts would be
responsible for the rest. and we hit
that balance and it seems to be working.
there is definitely some return in having
scouts responsible for administrative
paperwork. you know permission slips,
collecting money and things- but when
it comes down to it, the kind of
supervision that you end up
requiring for that sort of thing
make it virtually an adult function,
with a scout kind of going through
the motions and not really getting
much out of the experience at this
point. our adult volunteers do all
the paperwork and manage all the money.
we distribute cash to scouts, buying
food for a camping trip for their patrol,
making sure that a parent is cognizant
of this, but that's about the extent
that they handle funds directly.
none of the scouts have come to me ever
and said: you know, we really miss
being able to handle all the papers,
we really miss being you know.
you know, I don't think we've even
had a scribe for the past several
months because, a- there was really
no interest in it and, B- there's
not a whole lot for the scribe to do
and we could, you know, we could make
work for him. nobody's come to the
senior patrol leader or myself and
said, oh, I really really want to be
described. now I know that folks out
there probably make it work and make
it work really, really well and
that's fine. again, just describing
from my experience of my practice
where I've ended up. one of the
things about what the scribe used
to do was collect permission slips, and
we kind of almost eliminated
permission slips. I know that a lot
of people have made them online,
virtual things, but we still use
pieces of paper. but we started
collecting camping payments and
permission slips on a quarterly basis
and we did this for a number of
reasons. first of all, one of the
more practical things is is that
this reduces everything for a
given quarter, for three months, to
one transaction per family, and that
really simplifies our bookkeeping
and it really simplifies it for
parents, because they're not filling
out three permission slips and
writing three checks or making
three payments. the next thing that
we found that we've benefited
greatly from is we know who will
be participating in what over the
next three months, and our planning
has then become more focused
and advanced. rather than waiting
a week or two weeks before the
camping trip to figure out who's
going and whether or not we're
going to have the critical mass
to pull it off. we know well
enough ahead of time if any of the
plans need to change because more
scouts or less scouts than we
imagined are going to be
participating in that particular
trip, and then we also use that
participation information to shape
how the youth leadership and the
composition of patrols will be
through the patrol leaders council.
so far we haven't had to make big
changes in the composition of
patrols, but we have had a
quarterly senior patrol leader
and patrol leader elections. we've
seen some changes there because
our quarters correspond roughly
to school quarters and scouts
who are participating in a school
activity like a team or a band
or a club which is usually
around for about three months
time, they can better gauge
their abilities to take on
responsibilities for that
quarter and they don't take on
a key responsibility like being
the senior patrol leader or a
patrol leader if they are not
going to be around for that
quarter and it's no harm, no
foul. we want them out
participating in things and
that's fine, but they also owe
it to their fellow scouts, if
they're going to take on a key
responsibility, to actually be
there. so taking this approach
is basically eliminated- the
problem of having somebody in a
position of responsibility who
then finds they can't even show
up to carry out those
responsibilities. now our
families so far appreciate the
idea that we have a deadline
for signing up 30 days ahead
of the commencement of the
next quarter and they can
better plan their calendars
that way and adjust for
conflicts. then they can
looking at an annual
calendar or looking at
everything once a month,
and so it's been working out
better for our families too.
and this arrangement makes
having a quarterly parents
meeting- a court of honor-
which I've spoken about in
the past few podcasts- a
necessity, and it seems like
we're talking to our
families on a much more
regular basis than we have in
years past. so I was talking
about a two-edged sword, and
the other edge of the sword,
when it comes to scouts
and money, is nearly as
sharp as the one that we've
chosen, and directly involving
scouts in the administration
of paperwork and money is not
in and of itself a bad idea.
I, you know some people make
that work. I'll just say once
again, I found that it cuts
into the diminishing amount
of time that they have
available to devote to scouts.
I'd rather have them
devote that time to things
that were unavailable to
them in other activities.
both arrangements could work
out. there's probably two
or three edges to this
particular sword and there's
lots of different ways of
getting things done. one of
my assistant scout masters,
who served in the Navy
and was in the submarine
service- actually we were
talking about things like
this once and he said: well,
it's kind of like we said
in the Navy, it's kind of
like making coffee. I don't
care if you perk the coffee,
if you drip the coffee,
if you you know it's
instant coffee, as long as
you end up with a cup
of coffee. the method that
you use, the way that you
get to it, is not all
that important to me and I
think as long as we're
providing opportunities
for scouts and we're
employing the patrol method
and developing character,
the way that money is
handled, it can work
a hundred different ways.
so I want to say thanks,
Brad, for for asking
that question and
well, we talked about a
little bit more than just
money there. we talked
about the effect of
scheduling and things,
and we're preparing for
the- our third quarter
of this type of
scheduling in our troop
and I've kind of
delayed writing or
talking about it
until you've employed
it for a year
and we have some real
confidence in it's
that it's a good method
to share with folks.
so this is kind of
an interim report.
it seems to be working
pretty well.
I'll have some links to
a couple of other posts
where we've discussed
scouting and money,
because there is a lot
of official verbiage
about how money
should be handled
and exactly who
does what,
and it's very useful
stuff and I'll direct
you to that
through those posts
which will be in the
podcast notes.
if you have a question
or comment for me
and like to get in touch,
it's an easy thing to do
and I'm going to tell you
how to make that happen
in just a moment.
well, thank you for listening
to this
three hundred
and
thirty seventh
edition of the scout master
podcast.
now here's how you can
keep in touch.
you will find
fifteen hundred plus articles
and all of the past
editions of the podcast
at scoutmastercgcom
and, while you're there,
you can subscribe
to receive updates
to the blog
and the podcast
by email.
you can join us
in the vast panorama
of social media.
that's right.
there are over sixteen
thousand folks
who like scoutmaster
blog on facebook.
we have a course
of tweeters on twitter
and we pin
his pictures publicly
with a parcel
of prolific printers
on pinterest.
you can watch this
at scoutmastercg
on youtube.
but
if you cannot
face facebook
and twitter
makes you better,
you have no interest
in pinterest.
you don't put the you
in youtube,
don't worry about it.
that's okay.
cranky old person,
you can zoom
into the late nineteen
nineties
and send me
a good old-fashioned
email.
I'm always available
at clark
at scoutmastercgcom.
that's CLA
RKE
at
scoutmastercgcom.
if all else
fails,
set your secret
decoder
pin
to B2
and commence
transmission
immediately.
I'm reading you
five
and ready to copy
by now.
it should be
abundantly
clear
that the scoutmaster
blog
and the scoutmaster
podcast
are not official
publications
of anyone
other than myself.
I am not endorsed
or sponsored
by any
scouting organization
or the Boy Scouts
of America
or anybody else
in the entire
civilized world,
or uncivilized world
for that matter.
it's just me
talking into a microphone,
trying to lend
a hand to
scouts
and have a little bit
of fun along the way.
and speaking of fun,
let's bring him back,
shall we?
here's our founder,
Sir Robert Baden Powell.
Sir Robert,
good luck to you
and good camping.
why? thank you, sir.
feel better,
Brandon,
until next time,
everyone
you.